des fumigènes lancés par des opposants
au projet des verts ont déclenché les
alarmes incendie donc interruption du
conseil municipal durant 20 minutes puis
il est enfin question du dossier tant
attendu le projet a été revu et très
corrigé moins de logements on passe de
11 150 à 500 ou 600 logements et plus
des espaces verts préserver la majorité
très plurielle se serre les coudes même
l'ancien adjoint socialiste à
l'urbanisme qui avait défendu le projet
initial vote pour le nouveau c'est un
résultat aussi de lait coûte que l'on a
eus avec la convention citoyenne oncle
était normal sur cette position là aussi
après un débat interne on puisse évoluer
vous avaler des couleuvres non j'ai pas
l'impression par contre je regarde le
réel je regarde l'évolution climatique
je regarde le fait qu'on revoit
l'ensemble d'une politique publique en
fonction du prisme écologique aussi et
donc c'était une solution de compromis
et j'espère vraiment que cet écoquartier
enfin pouvoir sortir de tels compromis
c'est le mot de la soirée une porte de
sortie même pour cette majorité embourbé
dans les terres dévêtent selon
l'opposition on attend de voir un petit
peu comment ce projet va évoluer parce
que même la majorité lors de la fin du
débat au sein du conseil municipal n'a
pas été en capacité de nous dire
clairement ce qu'ils allaient faire sur
le projet des bêtes en nous disant
simplement c'est une porte de sortie
mais c'est pas suffisant aujourd'hui ça
se fait sur le dos des bisontins parce
que c'est de l'argent public moi je
refuserais qu'on se trouve dans une
villa ou pour y habiter il faut soit
avoir de bons de gros moyens soit être
en situation difficile pour avoir accès
au logement public je crois que c'est
pas l'avenir que je veux pour besançon
je veux une ville où la classe moyenne
puisse continuer à vivre
et être la dynamique qui manque
aujourd'hui à besançon pas assez de
logements pour le groupe mrm modem trop
floue pour les républicains l'opposition
s'abstient le projet est voté par toutes
les voix de la majorité mais entre
nouvelles études et recours judiciaires
les logements ne sont pas encore sortis
de terre